Speaker 1: Welcome back, everybody, to the David
Parkman Show. Former Republican Congressman Will
Hurd is joining the ranks of Republicans jumping
into this 2024 presidential primary. It is getting
very, very for Will Hurd, like I said, was a
congressman and he also worked in the CIA and he's
kind of known as a more moderate Republican and
he is more moderate. He's criticized Trump. It's
another example, though, of someone who I don't
really understand how he fits into the picture,
how he would win a Republican primary
with how MAGA the GOP is right now.
But here's this from CNN Former Texas
Representative Will Hurd launch his 2024
bid for GOP presidential nomination. Former Texas
representative will Hurt on Thursday launched
a bid for the 2024 Republican presidential
nomination. Joining a crowded field looking
to challenge frontrunner former President Donald
Trump. Look at him talking about why he announced
in just a moment. But continuing. Hurd has been
outspoken in his criticism of Trump following
the former president's indictment on federal
charges over his alleged mishandling of classified
documents. Trump has pleaded not guilty to all
charges. And then interestingly, it lists everyone
in the race right now, in case you've forgotten,
you have dissenters, you have Mike Pence,
you have Tim Scott, you have Nikki Haley, you
have Asa Hutchinson, Chris Christie, Doug Burgum,
Vivek Ramaswamy, Francis Suarez and Larry Elder,
and now Will Hurd. So with that being said,
here's this from CBS Mornings where
he's making this announcement.
Speaker 3: One that everybody know that this
morning I filed to be the Republican nominee
for president of the United States. This is
a decision that my wife and I decided to do
because we live in complicated times and we need
common sense. There are a number of generational
defining challenges that we're faced with in
the United States of America. Everything from
the Chinese government trying to surpass us as
the global superpower. The fact that inflation
is persistent at a time when technologies like
artificial intelligence is going to upend every
single industry and our kids or their scores in
math, science and reading are the lowest they've
ever been in this century. These are the issues
we should be talking about. And to be frank,
I'm pissed that we're not talking about these
things. I'm pissed that our elected officials are
telling us to to hate our neighbors. Our neighbors
are not our enemies. There are fellow Americans
who we just happen to have a disagreement with.
These are the issues that that we should be
talking about. And I believe the Republican Party
can be the party that talks about the future,
not the past. We should be putting out a
vision of how do we have unprecedented peace,
how do we have a thriving economy, how do
we make sure our kids have a world class
education, education, regardless of their.
Speaker 1: We'll stop it there. But, you know,
it's interesting. I have a former Republican
friend who still a friend, former Republican,
to be clear, and he's constantly emailing me
different people he thinks could be a good
presidential option. And he's like, obviously, I
know you differ with this person because I'm not
a Republican and any conservative I'm going to
disagree with severely, but would send me more
respectable options. Do you think they would
have a chance? What? They have a chance? Would
they have a chance in this Republican primary? And
I've had to explain multiple times. Unfortunately,
even though there are a lot of people that
I disagree with a lot but wish would be more
prominent within the GOP so that we could have
a more healthy, vibrant political discussion.
Unfortunately, this current GOP base, at least
there are moderate Republicans that still exist.
But the base that's the engine that drives the
agenda is so extreme. It's so MAGA that the
only person who really had a shot of defeating
Trump was someone like DeSantis, who is trying
to be a little Trump 2.0 and failing miserably,
apparently. Um, and it is, yes, terrifying. It's
so unfortunate, but that's the reality. And so
all these people who are jumping in, some like
Chris Christie that we talked about earlier, or
Will Hurd, who would be far better than Trump,
they're not going to have a shot because of
that fact, because they are more reasonable
than Trump. And that's just not what's selling
right now within the MAGA Republican Party base.